[Musik]
zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live im live stream zu aktuellen
ereignissen und diskussion und wir sehen
gerade das jens spahn der duh sind
bundesgesundheitsminister vor die
kameras getreten ist nach dem impfstoff
gipfel im kanzleramt wo er sich zusammen
mit kanzleramtschef helge braun dem
wirtschaftsminister herr altmaier und
vizekanzler olaf scholz getroffen hat um
über die kritik an der arzneimittel an
der impfstoff bestellung und verteilung
sich zu äußern und wir schalten sofort
rüber nach berlin zu sein worden
deswegen auch noch mal allen hier in
dieser runde alles ist schon wieder so
schnell begonnen das ja alles gute zum
neuen jahr in dieser schwierigen zeit
und auf weitere informative
zusammenarbeit in auch einer zeit wo das
informationsbedürfnis naturgemäß ein
sehr hohes und großes ist die
ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsidenten haben gestern
zusammen mit der bundesregierung
beschlossen die krone auflagen
fortzusetzen und teilweise zu
verschärfen
das bedeutet weiter tiefe einschnitte in
den alltag vieler bürgerinnen und bürger
und in das öffentliche leben
das ist schmerzhaft aber das ist
notwendig um langfristig die
infektionszahlen unter kontrolle zu
bekommen und zu behalten und es ist
nicht zuletzt notwendig auch angesichts
der weiterhin sehr stark belasteten
situationen in unseren kliniken und auf
den intensivstationen und so ziele dabei
die pandemie in den griff zu bekommen
pflegekräfte und ärztinnen und ärzte in
den krankenhäusern und in den praxen zu
entlasten und vor allem die besonders
gefährdeten bevölkerungsgruppen zu
schützen das geht zum einen vor allem
das ist im grunde das instrument das wir
seit beginn der pandemie nutzen das geht
vor allem über kontakt beschränkungen
und reduzierung um es diesem virus
wirklich schwer zu machen sich zu
verbreiten wie gestern auch beschlossen
und das geht zum anderen besonders und
besonders nachhaltig über das impfen
am 27 dezember des vergangenen jahres
haben wir in deutschland die
impfkampagne
gestartet seitdem sind fast 400.000
menschen vor allem in pflegeheimen
geimpft worden
wir wollen diejenigen zuerst schützen
die am verwundbarsten sind in
pflegeeinrichtungen die älteren und
diejenigen die sie pflegen und betreuen
wenn das geschafft ist wenn einmal die
pflegebedürftigen und die ältesten in
unserer gesellschaft kennt sind dann
verliert diese pandemie schon einen
großen teil ihres schreckens
angesichts der aktuellen debatte
angesichts der aktuellen lage sollten
wir uns auch dieses wichtigen a ziel das
erste ziel ein etappenziel nämlich alle
pflegeeinrichtungen in allen
pflegeeinrichtungen die bewohnerinnen
und bewohner zu impfen immer wieder vor
augen halten die tage des impfstatus
sind tage der zuversicht
impfen ist der schlüssel um diese
pandemie diese jahrhundert situationen
zu bewältigen impfen ist der weg raus
aus der pandemie und wir haben gemeinsam
diesen weg begonnen
und deshalb verstehe ich auch die
ungeduld vieler bürgerinnen und bürger
beim impfen ich verstehe dass viele
fragen haben in teilen verunsichert sind
wenn dinge am anfang nicht sofort
überall funktionieren oder nicht so
funktionieren wie sie sollen
politik muss diese fragen beantworten
politik muss sicherheit geben muss
fehler beheben und aus ihnen lernen wir
die handelnden politiker stehen dabei
der pflicht der bürgerinnen und bürger
müssen wir werden dieser verantwortung
die fehler die dinge die besser gehen zu
sehen gerecht werden die dann eben
besser zu machen und zu beheben
aber die wahrheit ist auch dass der
impfstoff weltweit gerade ein knappes
gut ist
deshalb müssen wir priorisieren deshalb
haben wir übrigens über wochen auch die
debatte zur priorisierung ja gemeinsam
geführt öffentlich in vielen privaten
zusammenhängen wahrscheinlich in jeder
familie ist diese debatte geführt werden
und auch im deutschen bundestag
deshalb müssen wir große teile der
bevölkerung
um geduld bitten und deshalb sind die
aha regeln weiterhin wichtiger denn je
denn das wir anfangs zu wenig impfstoff
haben würden das war von anfang an klar
das ist auch schon seit vielen wochen
und monaten klar da geht es uns wie
allen anderen ländern in der
europäischen union und auf der welt
grund für den engpass für diese
knappheit zu beginn der impfkampagne
sind übrigens nicht zu wenig bestellte
menge sondern grund für die knappheit
sind die fehlenden
produktionskapazitäten die geringen
produktionskapazitäten zu beginnen
beyond inc pfizer zum beispiel haben
sehr früh deutlich gemacht dass sie
weltweit für den weltweiten bedarf nur
50 millionen dosen des ende letzten
jahres haben vor produzieren können
damit daneben auch eine weltweite
knappheit entsteht
die gute nachricht es wird so sich die
zulassungen ergeben die sich aktuell
abzeichnende auch bei aussichtsreichen
impfstoffkandidaten genug impfstoff für
alle in deutschland geben das sowieso
schon mit bajonett und moderner und wir
können insbesondere wenn es dann darüber
hinaus noch weitere zulassung gibt allen
in deutschland im sommer ein impfangebot
machen denn wir haben genug mehr als
genug impfstoff bestellt und zwar nicht
nur von einem sondern gleich von
mehreren herstellern noch dass ein
strategischer ansatz den wir sehr
bewusst gewählt haben nicht auf ein
pferd nur zu setzen sondern auf mehrere
heute rechnen wir mit der zulassung
eines zweiten impfstoffs von moderner
das gibt zusätzlich zuversicht denn
zusammen mit den impfstoffen vom
biontech bekommt deutschland alleine von
diesen beiden unternehmen bei montech
und moderner über die verträge die
abgeschlossen sind über 130 millionen
dosen allein von diesen beiden
unternehmen die verträge dazu sind da
wohlgemerkt nicht alles sofort aber im
laufe dieses jahres
das ist ein erfolg auch und gerade der
deutschen politik die darauf gesetzt hat
allen europäern allen bürgerinnen und
bürgern der europäischen union
zeitgleich den zugang zu den impfstoffen
zu ermöglichen und gleichzeitig genug
impfstoffe fürs eigene land zu bekommen
und zu sichern
das war möglicherweise schon sehr früh
mit der impfstoff beschaffung begonnen
haben
zunächst als im allianz zusammen mit
frankreich italien und den niederlanden
schon damals mit dem ansatz für alle 27
mitgliedsstaaten impfstoffe zu
beschaffen und dann ab juni 2020 über
die eu kommission die das gebündelt hat
nach einem gemeinsamen beschluss im
ministerrat der eu die eu und
deutschland haben im stoff produzenten
dabei übrigens auch zu jedem zeitpunkt
in den letzten monaten unterstützt auch
als noch lange nicht klar welcher
impfstoff wie erfolgreich und wie
schnell sein würde und wie er sich
entwickeln wird sollte bei leon tech
über die europäische union bereits mitte
des vergangenen jahres fördergelder
erhalten um produktionskapazitäten
auszubauen und der bund die
bundesregierung hat das unternehmen wie
auch andere unternehmen in deutschland
zu dieser zeit ebenfalls bereits massiv
mit forschungsgeldern unterstützt
ohne diese hilfe ohne diese
unterstützung wäre der eben statt in
deutschland und in europa und auch
weltweit kaum möglich gewesen
das ist unsere bemerkenswerter da erst
am neunten november tatsächlich klar war
wie wirksam
der ballon tech im stoff wirklich ist
denn erst dann waren die daten aus der
phase 3 studie veröffentlicht und
bekannt die eine wirksamkeit von mehr
als 90 prozent belegen lange vorher
hatte deutschland bereits zugesagt sehr
große mengen impfstoff dosen von beyond
es über eu-verträge abzunehmen und erst
durch diese grossvolumige zusage
deutschlands ist es überhaupt möglich
geworden diese verträge auf zu schließen
weil deutschland damit eben auch
verantwortung und ja auch ein stück
risiko auch für andere mitgliedstaaten
die vielleicht auch wirtschaftlich
schwächer sind übernommen hat die
bundesregierung unternimmt weiterhin
alles um beyond ich aber auch die
anderen unternehmen denen der impfstoff
forschung und herstellung tätig sind zu
unterstützen
dazu haben wir uns heute mit den
zuständigen fachministern und der
bundeskanzlerin ausgetauscht unser
gemeinsames ziel ist es dass das
unternehmen bei und ich in diesem fall
so schnell wie möglich einen weiteren
produktionsstandort in marburg eröffnen
kann
wenn alles gut geht ist das im februar
der fall dann könnte das unternehmen
seine impfstoff produktion massiv
ausbauen
das hilft europa und das hilft vor allem
auch uns in deutschland denn das führt
zu früheren lieferungen von bestellten
dosen und das ist übrigens deutlich
effektiver als zwangs lizenzen zu
verteilen oder unternehmen zu
beauftragen die bisher noch gar nicht
mit diesen impfstoff oder überhaupt in
der impfstoffproduktion tätig war
meine damen und herren impfen braucht
vertrauen
in die zuverlässigkeit des impfstoffs in
das verteilungsverfahren in die
organisation
ich verstehe das bedürfnis nach einer
beschleunigung der impfkampagne
wir alle wollen möglichst schnell zu
unserem normalen leben zurück aber
dieser wunsch nach schutz und nach
normalität sollte uns nicht den blick
auf die fakten versperren und auch das
was tatsächlich realistisch in kurzer
zeit möglich ist
und es sollte nicht unsere prioritäten
gefährden wir müssen zunächst und wollen
zunächst diejenigen schützen die
besonders verletzlich besonders
verwundbar sind durch dieses virus so
viel solidarität so viel geduld muss
auch auf dem weg raus aus dieser
pandemie seien
vielen dank wir kommen zu ihren fragen
unserem relativ viele fragen auch online
erreicht wir fangen aber mal erst hier
verraten
vielen dank nochmal nachfrage zu der eu
bestellung erwarten jetzt an der web
reißen oder ihm das mangelnde vertrauen
in diese neue technik
der grund für verspätete verhandlungen
in der form oder rasant doch die
haftungsfragen der wesentliche grund
dafür
und meine zweite frage geht um die
sequenzierung des virus es gestern in
den beschlüssen zwischen den
ministerpräsidenten und der kanzlerin
war ja angekündigt worden dass sie jetzt
eine neue vorlage in verordnung
erarbeitet werden eher wann wird die
vorliegen und wie wird der inhalt seien
bei der sequenzierung des virus um
mutationen und veränderungen die ja bei
einem virus normal sind aber die eben
tatsächlich auch folgen haben können
etwa in der übertragbarkeit oder auch im
bereich der gesundheitlichen entwicklung
des schadens entstehen kann
nach zu verfolgen ist uns von anbeginn
sehr sehr wichtig gewesen auch gemeinsam
mit dem konzert ihr labor bei der
charité professor osten aber auch dem
robert koch institut zusammen mit
anderen laboren in deutschland das ist
jetzt auch noch mal natürlich
hochgefahren und
bewusst seien genau darauf zu schauen
jetzt mit blick auf vereinigtes
königreich und südafrika seit dem
vierten advent noch mal in der
koordination verstärkt gleichzeitig
macht es aber eben sinn und das hat das
dritte bevölkerungsschutz gesetz seit
ende november möglich gemacht dass
regelhafte und umfassender zu machen
dafür hat der deutsche bundestag mehr
also dem bundesministerium für
gesundheit eine verordnungsermächtigung
gegeben mit zustimmung des bundesrates
er was dazu führt dass wir eben jetzt
diese vorbereiten zügig dann in die
abstimmungsprozesse gehen auch mit den
ländern deren zustimmung wir dazu
brauchen und daneben in den nächsten
wochen schnellstmöglich aber eben auch
gründlich diese verordnung die er dann
die frage regel muss wer informiert wie
über was welche befunde werden überhaupt
eingereicht welche werden an wen
gemeldet wie wir das vergütet das ist
ein zusätzlicher aufwand all diese
fragen
das alles muss geregelt werden und dass
er arbeiten wir gerade die frage des m
rna impfstoffes als neuen als neuer
technologie für ein leben stoff ich
glaube das kennen wir auch aus dem
eigenen bekanntenkreis alle führt dazu
dass natürlich der informationsbedarf
besonders großes es gibt auch einige die
bewusst kampagne gegen einen solchen
impfstoff machen mit doch vielen irre
führenden aussagen an vielen stellen und
das hat natürlich immer auch eine rolle
gespielt dass wir sehr bewusst in der
strategie der eu nicht nur auf eine
technologie gesetzt haben sondern m rna
impfstoffe vector impfstoffe im protein
impfstoffe wir nicht richtig im kopf
habe auch also sehr bewusst auch dort
die vielfalt gesucht haben um auch in
allen bereichen akzeptanz hoch zu halten
der kollege hilfe
franke hatte in die erste frage sie
haben gerade moderner impfstoff
angesprochen können sie vielleicht
konkretisieren wie sich an der zulassung
durch die emea auf diese zahlen die sich
hier verteilt haben
zu den lieferungen bis mitte februar
auswirken würde also wie viele millionen
hinzu kämen und zweite frage wir haben
glaubhafte berichte erhalten dass
mediziner die impfstoff übrig haben zb
nach einer visite im altersheim diesen
ihren bekannten und privatpatienten
anbieten auch wenn diese nicht zur
priorität gruppe gehört hat das bmg in
welche hinweise auf solche fälle und ist
dies diese art von begünstigung ihrer
ansicht nach ethisch und rechtlich
vertretbar
zuerst einmal mit dem modernen stoff
erwarten wir für deutschland aus den eu
verträgen übrigens recht die zahlen
bedeuten davon 160 millionen dosen die
die eu mit moderner abgeschlossen hat
wird deutschland über 50 millionen
bekommen weil wir eben überall da wo
auch mitgliedstaaten aus welchen
erwägungen auch immer nicht ihren anteil
genommen haben wir gesagt haben den
nehmen wir dann auch für die versorgung
in deutschland also 50 millionen dosen
in diesem jahr zu erwarten
tatsächlich ist es aber auch so doch das
ist übrigens seit wochen kommuniziert
dass im falle einer zulassung von
moderner im ersten quartal knapp 2
millionen dosen nur zu erwarten sind
weil moderner das gleiche thema hat wie
alle anderen auch die begrenzten
produktionskapazitäten zu beginn und in
diesem fall ja auch noch vertragliche
verpflichtungen bei den vereinigten
staaten von amerika die frage nach dem
impfen nacht wenn das über ist also mir
ist das jetzt jedenfalls ihre
anekdotischen beschreibung die das tippe
ich ja mal ist nicht bekannt dieses
phänomen was ist gibt was ja dann auch
sinn macht ist dass wenn eben
tatsächlich impfdosen
übrig sind am ende des tages die sonst
verfallen würden das dann diejenigen dem
impf team sind das habe ich schon
mehrfach berichtet bekommen dann
tatsächlich auch dort geimpft werden das
ist übrigens nach priorität sogar
ausdrücklich auch vorgesehen dass die
die impfung vornehmen den impfzentren
arbeiten auch erkämpft werden können
sollen
ansonsten gehe ich davon aus und da habe
ich jetzt auch keine anderen indizien
dass er grundsätzlich die empfohlenen
priorisierung auch eingehalten werden
und gleichzeitig man dann im konkreten
aber immer ein stück pragmatisch sein
muss also das impfstoff nicht genutzt
wird
und irgendwie dann sozusagen verschüttet
werden muss weil er am ende des tages
über ist das kann ja eigentlich auch
niemand wollen aber ich bin bei hin das
macht sinn und ich weiß dass einige
länder das haben auch dafür geregelte
verfahren sorgen ich habe noch eine
frage hierzu moderne
sobald also gesundheitsminister jens
spahn zu der kritik an ja schleppender
impfstoff verteilung da gab es ja viel
kritik vor allem aus der opposition und
mit einem der oppositionellen parteien
oder mit einem vertreter dieser parteien
möchte ich jetzt sprechen nämlich mit
janosch dahmen gesundheitsexperte von
bündnis 90 die grünen haben
ich grüße sie jetzt haben sie gerade die
worte gehört von jens spahn der hat sich
gerechtfertigt ist es nicht zu wenig
bestellt worden es wird zu wenig
produziert trifft dass ihre kritik ja
zunächst mal hatte er auch gesagt
politik muss fehler beheben ohne dann
genau zu sagen welche fehler behoben
werden muss das greife ich gerne auf ich
bin angesichts der situation dass wir im
dezember 13 millionen impfdosen in
deutschland erhalten haben und bisher
nur rund 24 verstarben in größter sorge
es ist ein wettlauf gegen die zeit wir
müssen dringend schneller werden ihn
vermissen
dieser impfstoffe das bedarf einerseits
operativer änderung bei der vernetzung
und andererseits aber auch mehr
aufklärung und information hier würde
ich mir mehr vom bundesminister erwarten
und auch in der abstimmung der länder
mit den lieferungen der impfstoffe damit
diese dann schnellstmöglich bei den
menschen die sie jetzt so dringend
brauchen auch ankommen
was würden sie denn operativ ändern also
was müsste anders laufen in ihren augen
konkret geht ja darum und das ist jetzt
das allerwichtigste dass die ältesten
menschen in unserer gesellschaft zuerst
gehen werden und daher ist es ein stück
weit typisch deutsch die wir hier in
deutschland das ganze problem haben
angehen lassen nämlich zentralistisch in
diesen impfzentren versucht haben alte
menschen dorthin zu bringen und nur
einen kleinen anteil an mobilen im teams
aufgesetzt haben hier glaube ich jetzt
dringend erforderlich nachzusteuern alte
menschen haben ein problem damit
insbesondere auch außerhalb von
pflegeeinrichtung zum impfstoff zu
kommen hier müssen wir viel mobiler
dahingehend arbeiten indem wir
beispielsweise hausärztinnen und
hausärzten die impfstrategie werde
einbeziehen
die ihre patienten gut kennen die wissen
wo die hier sind und mit dafür sorgen
dass der impfstoff er zum patienten
kommt als dass ich ein hochbetagter
mensch auf einer app oder in einer
telefon- schleife im callcenter erst ein
termin geht lassen sich dann auch das
auch nicht auf andere länder zu herr
damen also niedersachsen zum beispiel
ist zb erst mobil rausgegangen dort sind
die impfzentren jetzt erst geöffnet in
hamburg sieht es genauso aus also da ist
ihre kritik doch ein bisschen pauschal
weil die bundesländer handhaben das doch
sehr unterschiedlich ja ein weiteres
problem ist dass es in einigen ländern
der fall ist das im moment noch ein
regularien verfolgt wird dass die zweite
impfdosen für die zweite impfung für die
patienten zunächst zur seite gestellt
wird und nicht verimpft wird aus sorge
es könnte nicht genug impfstoff
nachkommen oder nicht rechtzeitig
nachkommen
auch das verzögert eine rechtzeitige
swinton der vorhandenen impfdosen das
paul-ehrlich-institut hat noch einmal
ganz deutlich klargestellt dass das
fachlich überhaupt nicht erforderlich
ist und hier wäre es ganz dringend und
wichtig dass alle impfungen die auch da
sind oder aller impfstoff der da ist
dann auch tatsächlich direkt er vereint
wird kann man noch mal zurück zu ihrer
kritik dass quasi die mobilen impf teams
nicht ausreichend rausgehen und die
alten und schwachen gibt die gepflegten
oder die zu pflegenden impfen sondern
aufbauen der kühlkette ist ja doch mit
eines der großen probleme weil die
kühlschränke die diesen biontech
impfstoff führen müssen auf minus
80 grad sind rat diese stehen längst
nicht überall rum
diese infrastruktur aufzubauen ist doch
ziemlich komplex sind sie da nicht ein
bisschen ungeduldig sie leicht also wir
wissen inzwischen seit zulassung des
bayer geben stoff der in deutschland
zurzeit verwendet wird dass diese
kühlkette von minus 70 grad dann
erforderlich ist wenn man den impfstoff
sechs monate aufbewahren will für eine
kurze zeit heißt für einen zeitraum von
fünf tagen kann der impfstoff auch bei
deutlich niedrigen temperaturen die
konventionellen kommerziellen kühl
beziehungsweise gefrierschränken
vorgehalten werden können gelagert
werden und er kann auch aus nach
entnahme aus dieser kühlkette zu bis zu
sechs stunden transportiert werden das
heißt also diese zunächst befürchtete
situation dass man unmittelbar am
gefrierfach mit minus 70 grad gehen vom
vornehmen muss die es so nicht mehr
haltbar und im gegenteil der impfstoff
muss sogar aufgewärmt werden bevor er
berühmt werden kann
hier besteht durchaus handlungsspielraum
der muss koordiniert werden der muss
abgestimmt sein
aber gerade an der stelle wäre jetzt
anpassung erforderlich und wirklich
effizient menschen zu erreichen
wir haben ja doch ein in deutschland das
problem wir haben zu wenig
pflegepersonal wir haben generellen
mangel im medizinischen gesundheitswesen
sie sind ja selber erst das heißt sie
müssten das ja auch wissen dass es da
nicht einfach genug personal gibt das
jetzt irgendwie akquiriert werden kann
würden sie denn tatsächlich diesen
impfstoff auch selber verabreichen
können also es gab ja auch pannen dabei
also konkret ist es so dass wir die
größte expertisen verabreichung von
impfstoffen gerade bei hausärzte und bei
hausärzten haben die bisher kein
regulärer teil dieser strategie sind und
wenn man diese ressource mit einbezieht
dann haben wir menschen die jedes jahr
20 millionen grippeimpfung innerhalb
kürzester zeit durchführen
die ihre patienten kennen die im
vertrauensverhältnis haben die wissen
wie diese impfung und aufklärung geht da
verstehe ich zum beispiel nicht warum
wir das nicht systematischer einsätzen
nicht als reguläre struktur sondern
eingebettet in regionale impfkampagnen
das könnte man deutlich mehr machen
wir hatten in ihren augen jetzt hier
versagt es geht ja nicht um versagen es
geht sozusagen darum dass wir die dinge
gelöst kriegen und das geht nur
gemeinsam also erstens wenn es ums thema
information geht
ist der bund gefragt nationale
informations und aufklärungskampagne
zweitens auch zu steuern also den
ländern wirklich zu sagen wann kommt der
impfstoff denn wann wie wo bei denen
genau an
also eine vorausschauende planung zu
geben und zweitens natürlich in
zusammenarbeit mit den ländern und dann
auch regionalen strukturen wie den
gesundheitsämtern oder auch der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung gemeinsam
hier zu einem effektiven handeln zu
kommen
letzte frage an sie herr damen ihre
oppositions kolleginnen im bundestag die
linke und auch die fdp haben entweder
eine versuchung ausschuss gefordert die
fdp war dass die linke möchte eine
aktuelle stunde im bundestag einberufen
nächste woche halten sie das für
notwendig ich glaube es ist wohlfeil
jetzt dinge zu diskutieren die man hätte
im letzten sommer anders machen müssen
natürlich gibt es dinge und ich glaube
das wird ja deutlich auf allen
verantwortungsebenen die hätten besser
vorbereitet werden können aber im kern
geht es doch darum dass wir jetzt im
wettlauf mit der zeit sind und nur dinge
die wirklich dabei helfen auch jetzt
dinge zu verändern und zu verbessern
die sind jetzt angebracht und zu tun ich
bin gerne bereit nach der pandemie
situation unterhalten was die welche
lehren daraus aber im wettlauf gegen die
zeit jetzt zu dieser stelle zu sagen wir
unterhalten uns über die dinge im
letzten sommer das bringt uns nicht
weiter und ich würde hier vielmehr den
blick nach vorne richten wollen und
sagen lasst es uns vernünftig anpacken
fehler wenn ja aber in konstruktiver
fehler kritik um die dinge auch wirklich
für die menschen besser zu machen sagt
janosch dahmen gesundheitsexperte von
bündnis 90/die grünen im bundestag
vielen dank für ihre zeit wollte ich
danke ihnen und damit möchte ich rüber
gehen zu meiner kollegin nicole diekmann
im hauptstadtstudio berlin die hat sich
die pressekonferenz dass gerade auch
noch angehört die läuft noch parallel
viele journalistinnen stellen nach
fragen an herrn sparen
nicole wie willst du denn das ist
zusammenfassen was der
gesundheitsminister gerade da so gesagt
hat
angriffslustig selbstbewusst und auch
erstaunlich entspannt gleichzeitig für
das was da in den vergangenen tagen an
kritik auf ihn niedergeprasselt ist und
er hat zum einen noch mal inhaltlich mit
argumenten mit zahlen mit fakten
begründet warum die dinge laufen wie sie
laufen also einmal noch mal die
chronologie der bestellung dargelegt zu
welchem zeitpunkt wusste man über die
wirksamkeit von impfstoffen bescheid
warum hat man welche dosen bestellt
warum sind jetzt im moment so wenige
dosen überhaupt nur verfügbar und wie
lange im vorfeld wusste man das schon
und zum zweiten hat er auch noch mal
appelliert und zwar einmal an
solidarität denn ein wenig vielleicht
der knackpunkt in dieser diskussion ist
ja deutsche solidarität deutscher
alleingang auf der einen seite das was
andere im nationalismus nennen oder eben
europäische solidarität auf die man ja
gesetzt hat und auf die jens spahn auch
weiter setzen will das hat er gerade
ganz klar gemacht man bestellt als eu
zusammen damit alle auch gleichzeitig
auch die kleinen ärmeren länder
innerhalb der eu
die impfstoffe zur verfügung haben also
da hat er eben noch mal an die
solidarität appelliert und auch an
geduld wenn man ihnen hier gerade sieht
und eben auch gesehen hat und gehört hat
dann ist das so wie es läuft so wie er
es auch vorher angekündigt hat der
einzig gangbare weg für ihn also er
weist die kritik hier von sich sagt aber
auch und das ist auch das muss man dazu
sagen ich das erste mal dass jens spahn
das sagt fehler werden in dieser
pandemie gemacht es gibt keine blaupause
also insofern nimmt er sich da natürlich
auch noch mal aus der schusslinie indem
er sagt es kann sein dass fehler
passieren was wir immer machen aber im
prinzip ist das was gerade passiert
nichts anderes als das was wir im
vorfeld auch immer angekündigt haben wie
es erst mal laufen wird aber das ist
genau das was mir auch ein bisschen
aufgefallen ist so richtig viel neues
dabei nicht rausgekommen also hätte
dieses statement auch genauso vor einer
woche geben können oder
deswegen sage ich ja also ihren spahn
hat sich eigentlich hingestellt und
diese kritik komplett von sich
weggeschoben und
das interessante ist ja was er hier
gerade sagt ist auch an den
koalitionspartner an die spd gerichtet
und da hat er natürlich einen punkt da
hat die union auch einen punkt die spd
hat in den vergangenen tagen massiv
kritik geübt an ihren sparen an seiner
an seiner rolle die er spielt in dieser
bestellung als bundesgesundheitsminister
und da er hat es wird so explizit nicht
gesagt aber natürlich war die spd in
weiten teilen immer eingebunden in die
entscheidung sicherlich nur zusammen
kabinett sondern spd minister innen
sitzen mit im chor oder kabinett
insofern kann jens spahn eigentlich im
moment gar nicht anders vorgehen
strategisch kommunikativ als zu sagen
ihr habt doch alle vorher bewusst ich
sehe hier keine überraschung
ich habe jetzt bild hier ein paar fragen
aus der zuschauerschaft mich aber noch
eine frage mal von mir noch an dich
dazwischen schieben
er hat ja gesagt und auch nicht zum
ersten mal der grund dass es nicht mehr
als 1,3 millionen dosen gibt es ist
nicht das zu wenig gestellt wurde was ja
ein großer kritikpunkt ist sondern dass
die impfmittel also dass biontech nicht
genug impfstoffe herstellen kann ist das
glaubhaft ich meine gerade bei montech
chef
sahin hat ja gesagt er habe sich
gewundert dass die eu nicht mehr
bestellt habe naja das ist insofern
stringent in der kommunikation als auch
gestern nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz angela
merkel noch einmal auf das geplante werk
von bayern tag in marburg verwiesen hat
dass man jetzt nach kräften unterstützen
will auch von seiten des bundes mit viel
geld da aber darum geht es ja das hat
jetzt sparen auch gerade einmal
aufgegriffen man setzt jetzt auf dieses
werk in marburg das eigentlich viel viel
später erst in die produktion mit
einsteigen sollte das jetzt im februar
märz fertiggestellt werden soll
also das ist das ist ein roter faden der
sich hier generell durch die ganze
kommunikation jahrzehnt sowohl bei den
ministerpräsidentin den gestern als auch
heute bei ihren sparen das prinzip
hoffnung
man hofft darauf dass dieses werk
möglichst früh fertig gestellt wird man
hofft darauf dass zum beispiel heute der
der impfstoff zugelassen wird von
moderner und man hofft auch darauf das
ging aus dem papier gestern hervor das
dem ministerpräsidenten vorgelegt haben
für ihre beschlüsse dass eine immunität
entsteht nach einer impfung das weiß man
im moment überhaupt noch nicht ob man
nach einer impfung ki moon ist also man
sieht ganz deutlich diese zweite säule
auf die man jetzt so sehr setzt das
impfen da sind noch viele fragezeichen
offen aber diese säule ist immens
wichtig und nochmal diese appelle von
sparen gerade an geduld und solidarität
da sieht man auch man man hofft auch
sehr darauf dass die bevölkerung jetzt
weiter mitzieht
ich glaube wir müssen noch mal kurz
erklären oder klären was du gesagt hast
mann ist nach einer impfung schon immun
aber es geht ja um die sterile immunität
glaube ich glaube das hast du gemeint
dass man trotzdem noch andere anstecken
kann das ist nicht geklärt ob das
tatsächlich der fall ist weil es gibt ja
doch durchaus impfstoffe er doch noch
gezählt ab wenn ich trotzdem ein vorbild
erkrankt warum meinst du dass es kann
auch sein dass man dass man nach einer
ansteckung dann einen leichteren verlauf
hat es geht darum erstmal im moment geht
es darum den schwereren verlauf damit
abzuhören
okay das war wichtig dass er heute noch
fragezeichen konkret dass es trotzdem
wichtig dass das nochmal konkretisiert
habe nicht hinterher heißt das zdf sagt
die impfung wird nicht mit vielen dank
an dieser stelle für seine
einschätzungen das ganze wird uns weiter
begleiten und wir werden mit sicherheit
weil gute miteinander reden und damit
möchte ich dann doch noch mal über die
medizinischen fragen sprechen mit einem
experten dafür nämlich mit dem verband
der forschenden arzneimittelhersteller
und dort mit dem sprecher rolf hömke der
uns jetzt zur verfügung steht um
tatsächlich ja diese ganzen
wissenschaftlichen fragen noch mal zu
beantworten henkel jetzt haben wir
gerade auch ein bisschen verwirrung
gehabt was tatsächlich die wirksamkeit
des impfstoffes angeht können sie das
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz
konkretisieren
von den impfstoffen die jetzt entweder
schon zugelassen sind oder wo es heute
um die zulassung geht von denen weiß man
dass sie eine sehr hohe zuverlässigkeit
von über 90 prozent darin haben dass
menschen nicht erkranken
dass sie also keine mit 19 symptome
zeigen was man noch nicht weiß ist ob
diese menschen nicht vielleicht doch
viren mit sich tragen könnten und dann
doch andere leute anstecken obwohl sie
selber gar nicht krank werden was man
auch noch nicht weiß ist wie lange hält
denn diese schutzwirkung an
man sieht aus den studien dass es auf
alle fälle einige monate ist aber wie
viel monate es am letztlich sein werden
vielleicht sogar jahre
das weiß man natürlich erst im laufe der
zeit so wir haben hier aus unserer
zuschauerschaft jede menge ja fachfragen
an sie ich würde mal mit einer anfang
die sich tatsächlich ein bisschen
aufbringt jetzt warum wird nicht ein
strategiewechsel gefahren also es gibt
ja durchaus andere asiatische länder die
ganz anders vorgehen mit mehr mit daten
tracking apps arbeiten mit
temperaturmessungen quasi in allen
öffentlichen orten das ganze versuchen
in den griff zu kriegen würden sie den
empfehlen diesen strategiewechsel also
wie eine pharmaindustrie wir können
impfstoffe beisteuern und es wird sehr
intensiv daran gearbeitet auch
therapeutische medikamente fertig zu
stellen die dann eben dann helfen können
wenn menschen leichter krank sind dass
es gar nicht schwerer wird oder wenn sie
schwer erkrankt sind dass es nicht
lebensbedrohlich wird wir können anderer
maßnahmen natürlich weder empfehlen oder
nicht empfehlen das ist aufgabe der
politik und der experten in der
epidemiologie hier beratend tätig zu
sein
okay es geht aber zu den impfstoff jede
menge fragen ich glaube die können sie
beantworten zum beispiel von peter
thomas auf youtube der möchte wissen die
firma bayer wollte prüfen ob der
impfstoff gegen das mutierte virus wirkt
diese mutierte variante die gerade in
großbritannien
grassiert gibt es dazu schon neue
informationen wissen sie doch etwas
die letzten informationen die mir
vorliegen sind von kurz vor weihnachten
da sagt er
die sagten das unternehmen dass es eben
entsprechende untersuchungen begonnen
hat dass die aber ein paar wochen laufen
und ich kenne denn das ergebnis noch
nicht
dann gibt es hier eine frage wie ist der
neue vorschlag medizinisch zu bewerten
den abstand der zwei nötigen impfungen
zu vergrößern also empfohlen oder
vorgesehen sind jetzt drei wochen
zwischen der ersten und der zweiten
impfung es gibt auch von jens spahn
nachdenken darüber diesen abstand zu
vergrößern eben um mehr menschen mit der
ersten impfung zu versorgen was können
sie dazu sagen
impfstoffe werden entwickelt und im
laufe dieser erprobung mit teilnehmern
untersucht man was ist die richtige
dosierung und was ist ein geeignetes
anwendungs schema also wieviel nach der
ersten impfung sollte man die zweite
geben damit diese immun wirkung
möglichst stark wird und nachhaltig wird
man hat da sich bei dem einen stoff eben
auf ein drei wochen schema hin bewegt
und hat das dann im ganz großen stil
ausgetestet man weiß also wenn man in
diesem abstand die beiden impfungen
setzt bekommt man die wirkung die man
auch in den studien gemessen hat alles
andere ein verzögern hinauszögern heißt
man begibt sich in unbekanntes gebiet
könnte sein dass es genauso gut ist
könnte es aber auch sein dass es dann
nicht mehr so gut ist das heißt die
empfehlung wie sie eben auch die
zulassungsbehörde ausgesprochen hat ist
wendet ihn so an wie er auch erprobt
wurde und das gilt natürlich für jeden
weiteren impfstoff auch wo liegen denn
gerade die probleme in der
impfstoffproduktion also das ist ja
tatsächlich eine sache die hat herr
spahn gerade gesagt tatsächlich das
größte problem in seinen augen oder nach
seinen worten macht das nicht genug
impfstoff hergestellt werden kann wie
kompliziert ist dass und wie viele
braucht man dafür eigentlich
irgendwo bei uns und wir herstellung ist
immer sehr sehr kompliziertes mit das
anspruchsvollste was es in der
arzneimittelproduktion überhaupt gibt
braucht viele stufen ganz enge
fertigungstoleranzen ganz ganz viele
kontroll schritte damit man sicher ist
ja auch dieser arbeitsschritt ist
richtig verlaufen da ist sehr viel
biotechnologie im spiel und viele viele
weitere schritte so
dazu kommt jetzt bei diesen ersten
impfstoffen von bayern durch kaiser und
moderner handelt es sich um impfstoffe
eines typs den mann noch nie
großtechnisch produziert hat man hat
früher nur die kleinen mengen für die
studien gemacht es gibt noch keinen
impfstoff dieses typs bisher gegen
irgendeine andere krankheit das heißt
man hat also in weniger als einem jahr
eine großproduktion für einen völlig
neuen anders herzustellenden impfstoff
typ hochgezogen und das gleich an
mehreren stellen
bei den beiden genannten unternehmen
aber andere unternehmen sind auch mit
dazu gekommen die haben aufgebaut dass
sie bestimmte fertigungsschritte eben
auch durchführen können und das hinunter
einem jahr zu schaffen
das haben viele in der branche
eigentlich für unmöglich gehalten dass
wir sind also eigentlich in der
glücklichen lage dass wir jetzt
überhaupt schon großproduktion haben und
das ist eine enorme leistung und da
werden die firmen natürlich auch
anknüpfen in diesem sinne werden sie
weitere firmen suchen und hoffentlich
finden die eben auch parallel zu ihnen
noch einzelne fertigungsschritte machen
können oder die impfstoffen lizenz
produzieren da ist hoffentlich noch viel
weiteres möglich wir haben gerade gehört
das eben auch dieses werk was beyond
advisor eben dann in marburg betreiben
werden dass das möglicherweise doch
schneller schon serienreif produzieren
kann als man das ursprünglich wollte
weil man auch da enorme manpower
reingesteckt hat das zu schaffen
also das ist der weg und ja natürlich
haben wir jetzt weniger als wir uns
wünschen aber eben von einem stoff den
man vor wenigen monaten noch überhaupt
nicht in großen mengen hätte produzieren
können
wie können sie dann
kurz erklären wie lange das dauert und
werk aufzubauen also ist das eine sache
die innerhalb von zwei monaten geht
dauert das ein halbes jahr oder woran
hängt das wenn sie wenn sie ein werk
haben dass grundsätzlich überhaupt sich
schon auf diese art von
herstellungsschritte versteht dann ist
es offensichtlich das haben wir jetzt
gesehen bei intensiver arbeitende sache
von monaten das dann so zu justieren um
technik zu ergänzen die mitarbeiter zu
schulen und so weiter
dass man auch da diesen
herstellungsschritte durchführen kann
wenn sie wirklich auf der grünen wiese
neues werk errichten wollen dann
brauchen sie jahre
sie brauchen eben wirklich sie brauchen
erstmal im bauplan eine baugenehmigung
dann müssen sie diese halle errichten
die muss natürlich allen reinheitsgebote
entsprechen dann kaufen sie die technik
ein bei spezialisierten anbietern die
haben auch im moment ziemlich viel
auslastung also dann bauen sie die
allmählich ein sie fahren ihre anlagen
ein sie brauchen der umweltgenehmigung
sie brauchen dann die ganzen testläufe
um zu sehen ob diese maschinen wirklich
mit der genauigkeit das machen was sie
sollen und so weiter es ist eine sache
von jahren
ich habe noch eine frage von mich herein
auf facebook die ich interessant finde
weil ich den gedanken jetzt so gar nicht
hatte wer fragt wer es nicht spätestens
jetzt an der zeit bestehende
produktionsstätten von anderen
herstellern zu akquirieren um mit der
massenproduktion zu beginnen aber wenn
ich sie richtig verstanden habe ist das
gar nicht mal so einfach ne also jeder
impfstoff wird auf eine andere weise
hergestellt und man kann nicht einfach
zu einem anderen impfstoff hersteller
gehen sagen du kannst doch ein impfstoff
gegen tetanus machen dann macht doch
bitte jetzt auch noch diesen coup 19
impfstoff das ergibt überhaupt keinen
sinn weil die produktions der
herstellungsschritte einfach völlig
andere sind da stimmen die maschinen
nicht und so weiter und so weiter
der einzige weg der überhaupt sinnvoll
ist und das machen ja die unternehmen
auch gerade ist sie finden andere firmen
die eben aus welchen gründen auch immer
vielleicht für einen ganz anderen typ
von medikament einen bestimmten
herstellungs- schritt auch im prinzip
können und sich dann in kürzeren
zeiträumen
adaptieren dass sie den auch für den
impfstoff machen das ist der weg also
ich verstehe es so richtig ist ein
bisschen so nur weil eine firma eine
waschmaschine baut und was mit technik
zu tun hat kann die nicht auch gleich
umstellen auf einer auto produktion zum
beispiel das ist ein gutes bild in der
tat jetzt letzte frage an sie ich habe
gerade zu wissen herausgehört dass sie
eigentlich selbst verschieden sind mit
mit der geschwindigkeit mit der
vorgegangen wurde mit mit der dieser
impfstoff entwickelt wurde und jetzt
auch produziert wird ist die diskussion
ihnen ein bisschen ja zu ungeduldig die
ungeduld ist jetzt zu verstehen
die pandemie wissen wir alle wie sie
sich entwickelt hat
wir haben alle darauf gehofft dass
impfstoffe tatsächlich wirksam sind bis
zum neunten wussten wir dass von keinem
einzigen ob er wirklich schützt seit dem
9 november wissen wir ist vom ersten
kurz danach kamen auch gute daten eben
von dem von moderner wir haben jetzt
diese impfstoffe natürlich sind die
leute ungeduldig ich würde auch lieber
heute als morgen geimpft ist doch klar
und insofern verstehe ich es aber diese
ungeduld sozusagen muss sozusagen auch
natürlich mit konstruktiven
lösungsorientierten wegen verbunden
werden wie man jetzt vorankommt und wir
haben ja heute gehört was in der tat die
nächsten schritte sind wir bekommen
hoffentlich heute die zulassung für den
zweiten impfstoff dazu und dann können
auch da die lieferungen beginnen
es wird untersucht ob man es allgemein
zur regel machen kann das eben aus den
vorhandenen impfstoff gefäßen von bayern
de keyser mehr impfstoff dosen entnommen
werden können das würde auch noch einmal
zusätzliche kapazität schaffen wir sehen
weitere impfstoffe für die teile des
zulassungsantrags auch schon bei den
zulassungsbehörden sind und die
hoffentlich auch bald ihre
abschlussergebnisse mit dazu liefern
können das dann eben auch bald hier noch
weitere impfstoffe zugelassen werden und
das sind firmen die auch noch mal große
produktionskapazitäten mitbringen so
dass dann eben auch wirklich in
schnelleren
also schneller viel mehr impfstoff auch
nach deutschland kommt der kämpft werden
kann
ich habe noch eine frage an sie ganz
spezifisch zu medikamenten das ist ja
quasi das nächste wonach geforscht wird
wolfgang egger möchte dort wissen ob es
schon ja sechs medikamente gibt ihnen
aussicht stehen wie ist der stand da es
sind zwei medikamente gegen 9.10
zugelassen worden im letzten jahr ein
antivirale medikament und ein medikament
das immun dämpfend wirkt das heißt dann
in diesem spätstadium wo das immunsystem
nicht mehr hilfreich ist gegen die
krankheit sondern zu eskalieren droht
und selber mehr schaden anrichtet als
die wehren selbst das in dem moment
eingreifen kann
das ist schon mal ein stück verbesserung
aber natürlich hofft man auf viel viel
wirksameres der wurden eine reihe von
antikörper medikamenten entwickelt die
jetzt in letzten studienphasen sind zum
teil den usa auch schon eine notfall
zulassung haben die können den
studiendaten zufolge die viruslast
mindern und damit eben dafür sorgen dass
jemand der erkrankt ist nicht in ein
schlimmeres schwereres stadium kommt es
sind aber auch eine reihe weitere
medikamente jetzt in den letzten großen
erprobungsphase die in verschiedenen
stadien dieser krankheit verschiedenen
schweregraden dieser krankheit
wahrscheinlich positiv eingreifen können
die perspektive ist dass wir da
innerhalb dieses ersten halbjahres
hoffentlich mehrere zulassungen sehen
können dann sind wir gespannt und
hoffentlich guter hoffnung darin vielen
dank für ihre einschätzung gern
vormittag
darum ein dank an sie und euch fürs
zuschauen für die fragen und fürs
dranbleiben
wir sehen uns nächste beim nächsten
light steht wieder der kommt bestimmt
ganz bald denn wir haben ja gerade doch
wirklich genug zu berichten dass dann
aber sage heute das macht macht's gut
und tschüss